what about the interviews
you've had
a lot of conversations uh you give
acknowledgment to the people you've
you've done interviews with
uh well one I have to ask
as an inspiring interviewer myself
uh how people love to talk people just
love you know that and I've had 140
maybe 150 people they're all listed in
the back
one of the little things that people
won't notice but I'll say it now is all
of them are on the record getting them
to talk is easy they all want to talk
about musk but then at a certain point
say I don't put Anonymous quotes in my
book
I cite things
I say if you're tough enough
and you've gone through this and a lot
of times it takes two or three calls
back somebody will tell me so I say oh
no no I don't enjoy
but I think it's important to know where
everything came from and with mask it's
you know I had that from the very
beginning because I was a Time Magazine
reporter I'd worked reporter for the
Times Picayune or New Orleans I first
day on the job I had to go cover a
murder and uh I phoned in the story from
a pay phone and my editor that you know
the city editor said well did you talk
to the family I went no Billy I mean the
family you know the daughter just got he
said go knock on the door I knocked on
the door an hour later they were still
talking they were bringing me out her
yearbooks
lesson one I learned people want to talk
if you're willing to just listen
and whether it be Henry Kissinger you
just push the button and say kiss and
Jordan people tell you the stories all
the way through Elon Musk
everybody talked everybody in his family
everybody he fired everybody I mean
I think it's important to listen to
people and the other thing I learned as
a reporter back when I was covering
politics in New Hampshire in the early
campaigns
I learned from two or three great
reporters a guy named David Broder and
Tim Rosser the late NBC guy they do what
was called door knocking you just walk
in the neighborhood knock on a door and
ask people about the election but they
said here's the secret
don't ask any leading questions don't
have any premise just say hey I'm trying
to figure out this election what's going
on
what do you think and then stay silent
but musk a third secret you know this
well
he'll go silent at times
sometimes a minute two minutes four
minutes don't try to fill the silences
if you're a listener
you gotta learn
okay he's not said anything for four
minutes I can Outlast him it's tough
It's as humans it's very tough
respecting the silence is really really
difficult
I've speaking of demons
when there's silence all the demons show
up in my head oh dear the fear I think
is if I if I don't say anything it's
boring and if I say something it's going
to be stupid
that that the basic engine that just
keeps running not on the podcast well on
the podcast but also in human
interaction and so I think there's that
nervous energy when interacting with
people you can never go wrong
by staying silent if if there's nothing
you have to say not something I've
mastered but I do when I'm a reporter
try to master that which is
don't
don't ask complex questions
interject and when somebody hasn't fully
answered the question don't say well let
me you know I haven't just stay silent
and then they'll keep talking just give
them a chance to keep talking even if
they've kind of finished you're still
sometimes they haven't given you enough
instead of following up I'll just
nod and key Point you're making it sound
simple is there a secret to getting
people to open up more I'm somewhat
lucky because you know I started off
working for a Daily newspaper
and people back then
they want to talk to the newspaper
reporter but you also have a way about
you like I feel like you have uh like a
cowboy in a saloon like you just kind of
want to talk like there's a draw I don't
know
I don't know what it is maybe this I
don't know if it's developer you're born
with it but there's a it feels like I
want to tell you a story of some sort go
and tell me a story
a couple things
I did learn
to be more quiet I'm sure I know when I
was younger or even
I'll see videos of me at you know it
news things where I'm always trying to
interject a question and so you learn
to be quieter sometimes I haven't
mastered it I haven't learned it enough
you learn to be naturally curious many
reporters today when they ask a question
or either trying to play gotcha or
trying to get a news scoop or trying to
you know gig something that can make a
lead
and
if you actually are curious and you
really want to know the answer to a
question
then people can tell that you asked it
because you want the answer not because
you're playing a game with them
I'm sure some of them off the Record
some of them on the records you had
maybe you know
what just some incredible conversations
I was going to say some of the greatest
conversations ever but who knows some of
the best conversations ever are probably
somewhere in South America between two
drunk people that we never get to hear
so I don't I don't know but uh is there
a device you can give
from what you've learned to somebody
like me and how to have good
conversation
especially when it's recorded
well do we actually curious I mean every
question you've asked me is because I
think you actually want to know the
answer and you've done your homework
to be open and not to have an agenda I
mean we all
suffer from there being too many agendas
in the world today
yeah so they're just genuine curiosity
but
um there's something when you talk about
just one-on-one interaction
whether it's Elon or Steve Jobs or
there's something
beautiful about that person's mind and
it feels like
it's possible to reveal that
to discover that together
efficiently
and that's kind of the goal of a
conversation well I mean look you're
amongst the top
podcasters and interviewers you know in
the world today
you have an earnestness to you
um Ben Franklin is the person who taught
me
I mean by reading him the most about on
conversation he wrote a wonderful essay
on that it includes on silence uh
But it includes
trying to ask sincere questions rather
than
get a point across I mean
it's somewhat Socratic
but
whenever he wondered I wanted to like
start a fireman's Corps in Philadelphia
he would go to his group that he called
the leather apron Club
and they would pose a question why don't
we have it
what would it take what would be good
and then the second part is to make sure
that you listen and if somebody has even
just the drum of an idea
give them credit for it like as Joe said
you know the real problem is this
and
I do think
that
if I'm in situations and I just mean
even a dinner or something I'm with
somebody
I'm usually curious and I'll the
conversation will proceed you know with
with questions and I guess it's also
because I'm pretty interested in what
anybody's doing whoever I happen to be
with
and say that's a Talent you you have
which is you're pretty genuine in your
interests
the people
like Benjamin Franklin like the I'll say
Charlie Rose even though he's in
disfavor who interested in a huge number
of subjects and I think that helps as
well to be interested in basketball and
Opera and physics and metaphysics
uh that was a Ben Franklin that was a
Leonardo trick which is
they wanted to know everything you could
possibly know about every subject
knowable
but there's a different aspect of this
which is um that I would love to hear
how you've solved it or if you faced it
that you're certainly disarming
um see I'm like uh peppering with
compliments here trying to get you
that's a very disarming method yeah I've
recently talked to Benjamin Netanyahu
we'll talk again we're unfortunately
because of scheduling and complexities
only had one hour which is very
difficult very difficult with the
charismatically minister I understand
this but he's also a charismatic talker
which is very difficult to break through
in one hour
but there people have
built up walls whether it's because of
demons or because of their politicians
and so they have agendas and narratives
and so on and so to break through those
I wonder if there's some advice some
wisdom you've learned on how to uh sort
of wear down through water or whatever
whatever method the the walls that we've
built up as individuals I mean you call
it disarming which I don't know that I
am but disarming basically means you're
taking down their Shields also
and you know when people have a shield
and you try to give them Comfort I had
zero of that problem with Elon Musk I
mean it was like disarming to me which
is I kept waiting to say okay he's not
gonna they've got a shell or he won't do
that but
he was
um almost
crazily open
and
did not seem to
uh want to be spinning or hiding or
faking things
um
and I've been lucky
doudna was that way Steve Jobs was that
way
but you have to put in time too in other
words um
you can't say okay there's a one hour
interview and I'm gonna break down every
wall it's like on your fifth visit yes
well actually it was one of the things
in my situation you learn
fifth visit is very nice but sometimes
you don't get a fifth visit sometimes
it's just the first date and um I think
what it boils down to and we said
disarming but there's something about
this person
that you trust I think a lot of it just
boils down to trust in some deep human
way and I think uh with with uh with
many other people I've spoken with
sometimes the trust happens like after
the interview which is really sad
because it's like oh man I've never been
in your situation where I have a show I
usually have
I'm not a first date person yeah yeah
well you know but then I'm lucky I mean
I mean I say lucky but I'm in print you
know print is a
couple thousand Euro medium but they're
those of us who love it well the nature
of the podcast medium is that I'm a one
one night stand kind of girl